divinity original sin - is a huge game
with a fair few challenges so obviously
we weren't going to be able to cover all
the tips in just one video thankfully
you clever lot left tons of great
suggestions in the comments of our
beginner's guide so here are seven more
tips to help you through divinity
original sin - as smooth move notes one
of the changes from the previous game is
that MPC's will notice when their
belongings go missing if you pickpocket
someone they'll Pat themselves down and
look around pointing the finger at you
if you're lingering if you pilfer a room
someone will come check out where their
prized painting is vanished - so make
sure you flee the scene of the crime or
be prepared to chat fight or bribe your
way out of the problem a side note about
stealing and thievery if you find a
chest that you can't lockpick just take
the whole down thing with you and open
it a few levels later
[Music]
a tip from Sondra Heian definitely
pronounce that wrong is to flee battles
if you're getting your god broken ass
handed to you enemies aren't scaled to
your level so you may come across bad
guys that will stomp you in one hit if
that's the case use the flee option get
out of Dodge and come back when you've
got another skill point or two under
your belt a very useful tip from say
Emma is how to effectively position your
party you can unchain character so you
can control them independently this is
super useful for getting your party into
advantageous spots sneak your rogue
behind an enemy for an easy backstab or
your spell caster or Wayfarer are
somewhere up high so they can get damage
boost once the fireballs and crossbow
bolts start flying the actual damage and
saved action points can really give you
the edge in some tougher fights no
veneer he'll correctly points out the
skeletons have an extra trick up their
sleeves their bony fingers can be used
instead of lockpicks meaning that you
can sell any real lockpicks to traders
for more potions and gear even if your
skeleton is a spellcaster it's worth a
level or two in thievery or equipping
them with an item that boost the thief
skill just so they can make the most
other pointy digits side note while
we're talking about fingers and hands
lizards can dig stuff up so no worries
if there's buried treasure and you're
short a shovel as Seraph PR mentions in
their comment teleporting can be
incredibly useful both in combat and
outside in the world in the first area
of the game you can find gloves of
teleportation which while not great when
it comes to armor stats do give you the
ability to teleport in combat this is
great for getting members of your party
into advantageous positions or out of
harm's way but my favorite thing to do
is teleport that pesky spell caster
right between your two melee fighters
when you're out in the world you can use
the ability to reach some faraway
treasure or teleport yourself so gaps or
even out of jail cells and keep your
eyes open for the teleporter pyramids at
the end of Act one you can really get
creative with a pair of these bad boys
sneaking them into hard-to-reach spaces
or balancing between party members
almost feels like cheating and since
your inventories are basically magic you
can move them between party members when
were miles apart
Catharine FM commented that it's
important to use your map effectively if
you've been playing divinity original
sin - you'll know it's a hugely dense
game there's no wasted space here
nearly every spot of the map has
something for you to find with that
being said you'll sometimes find
tempting excursions that you just aren't
ready for it may be a fight that's too
tough right now or some treasure you
can't unlock yet the game won't hold
your hand to make a note before you so
be sure to make a mark on your map of
what discovery you've made and come back
when you're ready for it be a locked
door a tricky dungeon and NPC are having
trouble persuading instead of wandering
around thinking I'm sure there was
something here jot it down in your map
just like you're in the scouts the final
tip that we have is to make sure you're
using the right person for the
conversation some characters will have
unique dialogue choices that you should
make the most of but more importantly
you should try to ensure that the person
doing the talking is the right party
member for the job use the character
with the best persuasion stat if the NPC
you're trying to convince as being a
stick-in-the-mud and if you're wondering
around leading a party with your main
character it's easy to forget that they
may not be the best choice when it comes
to talking to merchants so take note of
who's got the best stats and things like
bartering and persuasion so you can
charm your way to victory or save
yourself a few gold pieces so those are
some more tips that will hopefully help
you try them from the world of River lon
if you've got any more to add the
weirder the better make sure to leave
them in the comment section below and
they may just make it into the next
video if you want some more beginners
tips then make sure you check out our
previous guide and for more content make
sure you subscribe to GameSpot
you